- Grade your performance
this year.
- I'm probably one of my biggest
critics. I'm hard on myself.
- [Announcer:] Danny Green.
- [Announcer 2:] For three.
[Buzzer]
Bang! Green does it again.
- [Taylor Rooks:] Is there any,
like, just Kawhi weakness
you can chip at a little bit?
- [Laughing]
- [Announcer:] For 3!
I'll take it!
Ohh! Danny Green!
[Cheering]
- Oh, oh, oh.
- Here we go. Here we go.
- There he goes.
[Laughing]
- [Jay:]
So he just gets nervous.
- [Danny Green:] I need one of
these to eat the Clippers.
[Laughing]
♪♪♪
- What's up, everybody?
It's Danny Green,
Los Angeles Laker,
proud Tar Heel alum.
And I'mma "Take it There"
with Taylor Rooks.
I'm gonna bring her
to the animal kingdom
to check out some snakes,
tarantulas,
scorpions,
crocodiles, you name it.
It's an experience
of a lifetime.
We're gonna "Take it There"
with Taylor Rooks.
- [Announcer:]
Green for three.
That's the way the game started.
- [Taylor:] Danny,
you've got us spending
your off day at the Reptile Zoo.
- [Danny:] Mmhmm.
- Surrounded by
all of these snakes
and reptiles and everything.
So, my question is, why snakes?
- Not just snakes,
but all animals.
Reptiles, I think,
are very unique.
Took interest in how they eat
and how they operate.
So I appreciate
the opportunity to do this,
and show you around
a little bit
and introduce you
to the reptile world.
- Yes, as we* there's a lot
of reptiles in here.
- Yes.
♪♪♪
- [Taylor:] Reptile questions
for the reptile guy.
- Mmhmm.
- I'm gonna say
some NBA players.
- [Danny:] OK.
- You tell me
what reptile they are.
- OK.
- What fits them, OK?
- LeBron James.
- You know that little*
I don't know what kind of iguana
it is, that runs on water.
- [Taylor:] OK.
- [Danny:] He is a fast guy,
but more so how athletic
he is and explosive he is,
his reflexes and also to be
aware of his surroundings.
- [Taylor:] Anthony Davis.
- Um, there's so many reptiles
to describe him.
- Yeah.
- You can go with, like,
a Komodo dragon
or a big lizard.
It's hard to describe him
because of how long and active
he is and his reflexes
at his size.
- Giannis.
- Giannis, uh,
I would say, like,
a squid or octopus.
Like, they can be very big,
but they're explosive.
They can shoot, you know, very
fast and travel fast in water.
- [Taylor:] Kyrie Irving.
- Kyrie, I would probably
say chameleon.
- [Taylor:] OK.
- [Danny:] You know?
He can adapt and adjust
to many different things.
Chameleons aren't big,
but they're able to blend in,
they're able to hide,
and they're also
able to surprise you.
- [Taylor:]
So I was reading a lot
about snakes before I came here.
- Yeah.
You learned some stuff?
- [Taylor:] Snakes are
cold-blooded, of course.
- Uh huh.
- Are you cold blooded
on the court?
- I try to be.
Most of it is mental.
If you go in with that
cold-blooded mentality,
Mamba mentality, it allows you
to be more focused,
locked in and less fear
of making mistakes
and just playing
and having fun.
- Grade your performance
this year.
- I'm probably one of my biggest
critics. I'm hard on myself.
I would give myself
probably B-minus, C-plus.
I'm used to guarding
the No. 1 guy
and now Avery's got that.
And offensively, I'm used
to doing this, doing that,
and now I just
stay in the corner,
make sure I space
or set screens.
So figuring that out, but, um,
as I'm figuring it out,
I'm getting better at it
in spurts here and there,
but probably a C-plus,
B-minus.
- Are you the best role player
in the NBA?
- I wouldn't say that.
- OK.
- I try to be the best
role player for my team.
My job is to play defense
most of the time
and knock down shots
and space the floor
and make it easier
for our stars to operate,
LeBron and AD.
You know, we have
Dwight Howard,
who has, who's a great role,
blocking shots,
JaVale McGee, catching lobs.
So I just focus
on trying to be the best
I can be for our team.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- [Danny:]
Not just in the league,
but obviously,
that's a goal to have.
They don't give an award
for that,
but, you know,
I take pride in it.
- When you talk about
being a player,
talk about playing any sport,
you think success comes
with being the greatest,
but really, success comes
with being the greatest
at whatever your role is.
- Exactly.
I always liked,
you know, coach Phil Handy.
He's one
of our assistant coaches.
He goes, "Be your own GOAT."
So, it's pretty much
being the greatest*
you're being your greatest,
basically,
being the greatest
at what you do
or being the best you.
And I know
what I'm capable of doing.
Whatever they need you to do,
you be your best self,
on and off the floor.
- Let's talk free agency*
- Mmhmm.
- For a little bit.
Before, obviously,
deciding to be a Laker,
I heard you were potentially
gonna be a Maverick,
or you thought about it.
There were some rumors.
- Yes.
- Walk me through
the free-agency process.
- Dallas was very interested.
Lakers were interested.
But Lakers to me
were the front-runner
because of the pieces
they had now.
Dallas has some really
good pieces,
but I think it would take
a year or two
for them to be
in that conversation.
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- [Danny:] But yes,
those were the two
front-runners,
you know, outside of Toronto,
knowing what Toronto were
able to offer or not offer.
It was then, you know,
Lakers and Dallas.
- Yeah. You've shuffled,
you know,
around
different teams a lot,
so you've had different coaches,
different players.
- [Danny:] Mmhmm.
- How do you start
to feel, like, home?
Like, do teams start to feel
like home for you ever?
- Yeah. I think it's
the locker room.
A lot of us here felt at home
sooner than we expected to
because of how fast
we jelled as a group,
learning each other
on and off the floor
and then winning
and also having a culture,
building
a culture off the court.
I think it makes you*
allows you to feel at home.
- [Announcer:]
Danny Green answers.
- OK, reptile time.
I'm ready.
- I have a reptile expert
coming in*
- [Taylor:] OK.
- [Danny:] To help us out
and help you calm,
keep you calm.
- I'm calm.
- Here*
- [Dwight Howard:] Yo, yo.
- [Taylor:] What up?
- What's up?
Yay, I'm so excited.
- [Dwight:] How you doing?
- [Taylor:] Are you gonna,
are you gonna
help us here?
- I am going to help
you guys today. Yes, yes.
- And why do you like reptiles?
- Ever since I was a kid,
I always wanted
some snakes
and stuff like that.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- And my mom said
I couldn't
have 'em in her house.
- [Laughing]
- [Dwight:] So once I got out
of her house, I was like,
"I gotta get me some snakes."
- Yeah.
- You know, so I have
a big collection
of snakes, a wide variety.
- Oh, my gosh.
- [Danny:] There's not many
snake people in the league.
- [Dwight:] Yeah.
- [Danny:] So when we find out
about each other, we have, like,
this weird, random bond.
- Wait, who else in the league
likes snakes?
Is there someone
we don't know about?
- Uh*
- Yeah, Robert Covington.
- [Danny:] Robert Covington
for sure has one.
- No way. He does?
- [Danny:] Yeah.
- [Dwight:]
Yes, he has a snake now.
- [Taylor:] I love it.
- [Danny:] Yeah.
- [Taylor:] OK, and now, am I
gonna walk away with a snake?
- You might.
- Who knows?
- You might, you might.
- Here comes the real
professional right here.
- [Jay Brewer:] Oh, oh, oh, oh.
- He's coming on in*
- Whoa!
- With all the good*
- Oh, yeah. Yeah.
- Exotics.
- He got the goodies.
- All right, Jay.
- Dwight's, Dwight's
my assistant.
- So the best way to*
[Laughing]
- He's the man.
- [Danny:] The best way to do it
is you have to just jump,
like, jump right in.
- You gotta jump right in.
- [Taylor:] OK, all righty.
You just touch it?
Like, you just*
- Yeah.
- [Dwight:] Yeah, there you go.
You already ready.
- This is a nice one.
It's very pretty.
- [Taylor:] Am I holding it
right? Like that?
- You never really wanna
go and grab
where the head is at first.
- OK.
- Because to them, it's like
seeing a big bird
or a creature
trying to grab it,
so they might get
a little nervous.
- [Taylor:] Gotcha.
- So you always try to*
I always try to grab them in
their midsection or whatever.
- OK.
- [Dwight:] And then I'll just
let them, you know,
do what they do,
get comfortable with me.
- [Taylor:] This,
I like this one.
- You like this one?
- [Taylor:]
This one is real chill. OK.
- OK.
- As it goes in my hair.
I'm great.
- [Danny:] Keep*yeah,
you gotta talk, tell 'em.
- So now when you see him
wrap around like that,
he's just getting comfortable.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
Oh, that snake likes you.
- He's just getting comfortable.
He probably likes my hair.
- [Jay:] [Laughing]
♪♪♪
- You have played for three
very good coaches.
- Mmhmm.
- You've played for many
good coaches, but*
- Yes.
- Obviously Vogel*
- [Danny:] Mmhmm.
- [Taylor:] Nurse, Popovich.
- [Danny:] Yes.
- [Taylor:] Compare and contrast
their coaching styles.
Cuz I'm sure they're vastly
different in a lotta ways.
- For sure. I think Coach Vogel
and Pop are very similar
in the fact that they're
more defensive coaches.
Pop, if you don't play defense,
you're not playing offense.
You're not playing
at all, basically.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- [Danny:] So Frank is kinda
the same in that sense, but not
as, as a stickler as Pop was.
Nick obviously,
he emphasized defense,
but he's more
of an offensive coach.
He likes to push basically
up and down, get shots.
So I had a lotta fun.
We had more freedom.
We had a lotta freedom in the
offense. We pushed the pace.
- One cool thing, though*
and you've been on
so many teams
with some great players*
you know the ins and outs.
You figure out
those players' weaknesses.
- Mmhmm.
- [Taylor:] Maybe how to
stop them a little bit.
- Mmhmm.
- How do you stop Kawhi?
- [Danny:] [Chuckling]
- [Laughing]
- Well, as with all
great players,
there is no real stopping them.
It's trying to contain them.
- So give me the playbook.
We're trying to contain Kawhi.
- [Danny:] Um, we're
trying to contain*
- What do you do?
- I think the best thing
just with any superstar
is try to limit his touches
and try not to let him catch
the ball where he wants it,
try to deny him some,
double team him some,
throw different looks at him.
He's a tough player, and I said,
I know what he's gonna do,
and I still can't stop*
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- That's what,
that's what makes him great.
- Is there any, like, just
Kawhi weakness
you can chip at
a little bit in his game?
- [Danny:] No, not really.
And if I did,
I wouldn't, I wouldn't
put it out there to the people.
- You're like, you're gonna keep
it, keep it as a secret?
- Yeah. I'm keeping it, yeah.
- So how would you
describe Kawhi?
Cuz I feel like a lot of people
probably don't get it.
- [Danny:] He's a normal person,
just very simple
and likes things
the way he likes things.
He's the type of guy that
just, you know,
wants to be in the shadows
but also be great
at what he does.
- While I have two Lakers here,
I have a question for you guys
cuz I have been wondering this.
- OK.
- Take me into this,
like, Caruso craze.
- Ha!
- Everyone loves Caruso.
- That's the GOAT.
That's the GOAT.
- Yeah.
- I guess, in the league,
I guess this is not bad to say.
There's not a lotta white guys
in the league.
- Yeah.
- [Dwight:] Yeah.
- And he's one of very few
that's very athletic.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- [Dwight:] Mmhmm.
- [Danny:] He has a little
flavor in him.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- [Dwight:] Yeah, he does.
- [Danny:] He does
all the dirty work.
- [Taylor:] For sure.
- [Danny:] And people love that.
- What reptile is Alex Caruso?
- Ooh-wee.
- [Laughing]
- [Dwight:] I would say
he would be an albino lizard.
- [Danny:] Yeah.
- [Taylor:] OK, why?
- [Dwight:] One of those big,
one of those big dragons.
- Why?
- [Danny:] Komodo.
- He's fast.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- Bites hard.
He finishes hard.
- Bites*
- Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
- I love that. Great answer!
Great answer. Great answer.
- So, yeah, I wanna go
with that.
Yeah.
- [Jay:] OK.
How about this one?
- [Danny:] Oh, man.
- Oh, man.
- [Jay:] This is
an American alligator.
- American*
- This could be
AC right here.
[Laughing]
- That is a Caruso gator.
- [Dwight:] Yeah.
[Laughing]
- This is probably better to pet
and not his face.
- [Taylor:] Yeah. I'll pet.
- There you go.
Give him good support,
pull him tight against you.
- Mmhmm.
- There you go.
- This is the first time
I'm holding an alligator.
- Cool.
- [Dwight:] This one is crazy.
- [Taylor:]
Yeah, you wanna hold it?
- I'll hold it.
Let me see, how do we*
- Yeah, go ahead, grab the*
yep, right*
Hold him like a baby.
- Come here.
Come here, little baby.
- [Jay:] Now these guys*
- [Taylor:] [Laughing]
- [Jay:] These guys*
- Oh, oh, oh, oh.
- Here we go, here we go.
Here we go.
- There he goes.
- Here to rescue,
so all you do*
- There he goes.
- So all you gotta do is*
come on, we got it. We got it.
- Hold up, buddy.
- [Taylor:] We got it,
we got it.
- Here we go.
- Chill out, man.
- So he just gets nervous
cuz unlike a snake,
he doesn't want a tree.
He wants, he wants to feel like
he's on the ground,
so lots of belly support,
and he should settle
right back in.
- There we go.
- [Danny:] There you go.
- And we want him
to feel comfortable.
- [Danny:] A little wiggle.
- [Taylor:] Oh, I love it.
- [Dwight:] I need one of these
to eat the Clippers.
[Laughing]
- So we ain't gotta
worry about*
- Release it onto Kawhi.
- [Jay:] You know what?
- Yeah.
- I'll show you the bigger*
- "Here, Kawhi."
♪♪♪
- Funny little thing, but did
you really get drug tested
after that dunk
against the Hawks?
- I did.
- [Taylor:] Really?
- [Danny:] I did. The next day,
and I'm like,
"Why are they testing?"
Yeah, so it happened
the next day.
I think it was me, Alex Caruso*
he's another one that kinda
gets tested here and there.
It's hard to believe,
him do what he does,
I guess, on the floor,
athletically,
so they always test him
a lot of times.
But me, I'm older. They haven't
seen me do that in a while.
- [Announcer:] Go, Danny Green!
- [Another Announcer:]
[Laughing]
- Now, obviously that was
a good dunk that you had.
You've got dunked on
a couple times this year.
- I have, I have.
- [Taylor:] Jayson Tatum
I think is the one that sticks
out to a lotta people.
- Yes.
- [Announcer:] Ahead to Tatum,
one man to beat,
oh, and he throws it down.
- [Danny:] He's very athletic.
He's a tall guard,
and it happened so fast.
That's it*when it happened,
I tried to, like,
just cut him off,
but it was just too late.
- It was too late.
- It happens sometimes,
it happens sometimes.
- OK, besides
the obvious ones*
- Mmhmm.
- Toughest to defend?
- I think the non-obvious guys
to defend,
it wasn't like the James Harden,
the Kevin Durants,
but the ones
that are not obvious
are the guys that run around
so much, like the JJ Redicks,
the Kyle Korvers.
You're chasing 'em off three
and four screens,
off 7-footer centers.
You know, when DeAndre or Blake
was setting a screen for JJ
when he was in the Clippers.
So I think those guys
are the ones
who are tougher to guard for me
that were not the obvious ones.
- [Announcer:] More good D
from Green.
- I always ask my guests this
about their respective teams.
You both have to give it to me.
- OK.
All-time
Lakers starting five.
- Ah! OK.
Point guard,
Magic Johnson.
- OK.
- 2-guard, Kobe Bryant.
3, I gotta go LeBron.
- Mmhmm.
- 4, Shaq.
5 is Kareem.
- Ooh, that's a squad.
- [Danny:] That is.
- And you cannot take
that exactly.
- I'll take a different route.
- OK.
- I'll go a different route.
- No, that's good. That's good.
- I'mma go with Magic at 1.
- OK.
- Kobe at 2.
Bron at 3.
AD at 4.
And a lotta people
not gonna like this one.
I'm gonna go
Big Game James at 5.
- [Dwight:] OK.
- Really? Going Worthy? OK.
- [Danny:] Just, I have to go
with Big Game. I have to go Big
Game.
- So y'all trying to run.
- I do like*
Yeah, we gonna run.
A little small ball.
- OK, all right.
- So*
- Oh, my goodness.
- [Danny:] Oh, oh.
We have a*
- Gee!
- [Taylor:]
It takes, like, five people*
- We needed*yes.
- More people.
- Oh, my God.
- This is a snake.
- Ooh, whoo!
- Yes.
- We could use some help.
- Wow.
- There you go.
- [Laughing]
- [Groaning]
- Uh-oh.
We got a leak on the other end.
- Why* I'mma switch with you.
- Ohh!
- Leaking, huh?
Oh, there he go.
- Ohh!
- That poop stinks.
- She's about 11 years old.
- And she is dropping them.
- So bad.
- She said, "I'm trying to poop.
Y'all messing up
my bathroom break."
[Laughing]
- Cleanup on Aisle 6.
- Her poop bigger than mine!
♪♪♪
- So, on a team with
LeBron James and Anthony Davis,
obviously LeBron carries
a lot of the load.
- Mmhmm.
- He's LeBron James.
But Anthony Davis is also a star
and a great basketball player.
- Yes.
- What is that dynamic like
being on a team
that has these two
just all-around studs?
- I love it.
They embrace each other.
They're the best of friends.
They hang out with each other
and also embrace us.
- Besides chemistry*
- Mmhmm.
- What is going to be
the thing
that sets the Lakers apart?
- Our leaders. Our two stars.
Also, I think our depth,
that we have so many guys
that can play,
and are playing well,
that we don't have enough
minutes to play in the game.
It's not about us.
It's about the team.
So we don't really care about
the minutes.
As long as we're winning
and playing well,
you know, guys are fine with it.
- Lakers, good enough
to win it all?
- For sure. Definitely.
We just have to,
we have to do it.
We can't expect it to happen.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- We gotta make it happen
when playoff time comes,
you know, being locked in
and dialed in
to the matchups that we have.
- Who is the stiffest
competition
for the Lakers? What team?
- [Danny:] I think there's
more than one.
In the West,
I think there's a lot of them.
In the East, of course,
Milwaukee is very tough.
Philly is good
when they're healthy.
Boston,
they're very tough.
You've seen that matchup.
It's a very tough matchup.
That could be a finals*
you never know*preview.
You have three or four teams
in the West,
three or four teams in the East,
that can come out each side.
And it makes it more exciting
for basketball fans to watch.
- You mentioned the
Lakers-Celtics game this year.
Great game.
- Yes.
- What is that rivalry like?
Does it feel different
than others?
- For sure.
Um, it's very new to me.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- So I didn't know
what to expect.
Each time we play them is very
much like a playoff atmosphere.
Rarely do you see a rivalry
between two teams
from different coasts
and different conferences.
- Now, you said, "Who knows?"
Looking at the Lakers-Celtics
game could be Finals preview.
- Mmhmm.
- So in this hypothetical world,
let's say you're playing
the Celtics*
- OK.
- In the Finals.
- Mmhmm.
- Let's kinda run through
that starting five.
Tell me what problems
each of those players
gives the Lakers.
- [Danny:] I'mma start
with Kemba,
one of the top point guards
in the league.
Very crafty,
and with that system,
you're not
able to double-team him.
He's a tough cover.
Jayson Tatum,
a young rising All-Star.
Obviously a tall, long,
athletic guard
but can handle it
like a point guard
and has, you know, a plethora
of moves and can shoot.
Jaylen Brown, very athletic,
big guard,
plays in the post some.
Slasher but, said,
is a shooter as well.
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- [Danny:] Another tough cover.
Gordon Hayward.
He was a All-Star in Utah.
- [Taylor:] It really is
so many good guys, yeah.
- [Danny:] There's so many guys.
He can go both ways,
shoot it, has a good amount
of moves as well
and then shoots it
from perimeter.
Marcus Smart, the guy
with an edge,
scrappy defensive player
but also can shoot it
very well from the perimeter.
They have so many different guys
that can do different things.
It's a matchup problem
for any team.
- [Jay:] It's just
so he knows there's food.
- Come here.
[Laughing]
Ooh, yay!
- [Danny:] Yeah.
- [Taylor:] Wow.
- [Jay:] Gone!
- [Dwight:] Gone.
- [Danny:] With the*
don't bring him out here,
Dwight.
- [Taylor:]
Dwight, put it in!
- [Jay:] Oh, look at that.
- [Taylor:]
Everything I did here today
was my first time.
[Laughing]
OK, we have officially
fed the alligators.
- [Jay:] [Laughing]
- I have come and done
so many new things.
I'm officially a reptile girl.
So thank you.
- We'll get you a badge.
- I joined the reptile guys.
So thank you so much,
Jay, for having us.
- [Danny:] Yes.
- Thank you.
- Dwight, for being
a fantastic guest.
- [Danny:] Appreciate
your time, man.
- Total pleasure.
- We gotta come back
and do some of
the behind-the-scenes stuff.
- We'll have to come*
- I'm looking forward to*
- [Taylor:]
Y'all gotta come.
- We'll have to have
a boys' day out.
- Yes, yes.
- Let's do it.
- Appreciate the time today,
it was amazing.
- [Taylor:] Yes.
- A lotta fun.
- Thank y'all so much.
- Thank you.
- Take care, guys.
- Yep.
♪♪♪
- [Taylor:] All right, Danny,
so I play this game
with every guest.
- Yeah.
- True or false, and why?
You have to pick one.
Do not waver. And tell me why.
- OK.
True or false, and why?
Dwight Howard
is a Hall of Famer.
- True.
- [Taylor:] OK, why?
- All-time shot-blocker,
rebounder, scorer.
He's been in this league
for so long,
and he's done some unbelievable
things statistically.
- OK.
True or false, and why?
UNC produces
the best basketball players.
- True.
- [Taylor:] OK, why?
- Cuz I went to school there.
No, um*
- [Laughing]
- I think we have a lot
of great players
come from there that have
made a pretty good mark
in this league.
- Better than Duke?
- I would say so.
- All right, but you
have to say so.
- I mean, couldn't have it
any other way.
- True or false, and why?
Staples Center is now
the mecca of basketball.
- True.
- Over the Garden?
- Yes. Staples Center has two
very great emerging teams.
I wouldn't say the mecca,
but it's becoming the mecca.
- This might have been
my favorite episode*
- Really?
- In terms of the things
that we had to do.
- OK.
- Thank you so much
for having me,
like, hang out
with all these reptiles
and see something you are
clearly very passionate about.
- I love animals, but thank you
for the opportunity.
Thank you for bringing me
here to meet Jay
and also experience this.
It was a lot of fun.
It was definitely
an experience
I'll never forget.
- Absolutely. Be a snake.
- Yes, ma'am.
- [Taylor:] [Laughing]
- Be a, we'll keep
the Mamba mentality alive.
- Exactly. Absolutely.
- For sure.
- Thanks, Danny.
- Thank you.